foreign
[Music]
the world's smallest R environment
running r on a 15 computer
hi my name's Mark I'm the founder of the
R4 pie project and uh really excited to
speak to you about it today I hope
you're enjoying the conference so far
the awful pie project exists to make it
easier to run on the Raspberry Pi family
of computers it's been possible to run r
on them for a really really long time
but the experience is not necessarily
always a smooth one so the R4 pie
project really aims to kind of
smooth that process out to make it a lot
easier for folks to get started we've
got full documentation over at r4pi.org
and I'm going to show you some more
information about the project today
so what is a Raspberry Pi
the Raspberry Pi computer is a family of
computers that was first launched in
2012 so about 10 years old now
um and they're created by an
organization here in the UK called the
Raspberry Pi Foundation the foundation's
aim is really to
improve outcomes for folks through kind
of computer science and education and
things like that and the way that they
do that is they create a very very low
cost computer we started out with a
computer that cost 35 it's about the
size of a deck of cards and then there
have been multiple iterations of that
over the years and then at some point
they released a a smaller version of
that computer which only costs 15 so now
there are probably three main members of
the Raspberry Pi family
and we'll take a look at those in a
little more detail the Raspberry Pi 4
model B is the most common uh of the
Raspberry Pi family at the moment it's
the the newest kind of standard size
um version of the computer this
particular one is in a nice rainbow case
but the computer itself you can see how
small it is it's probably roughly the
size of a deck of cards something like
that
um they start at 35 that's the one
gigabyte model they go all the way up to
eight gigabytes of RAM
um it's a four core CPU at one and a
half gigahertz as a SD card slot
underneath for storage and all the
things you would expect from a modern
computer so USB 3 Wi-Fi Bluetooth HDMI
out that kind of thing
next we have the Raspberry Pi zero two w
this is the second iteration of the zero
size computer you can see that that one
is just over an inch wide
um
a little larger than a stick of gum I
guess
um those these are the 15 computers so
it has a four core CPU at one gigahertz
512 Meg of ram Wi-Fi Bluetooth HDMI out
and again the SD card for for the
operating system
and then finally we have the the largest
of the Raspberry Pi computers
um but that's only because it's built
inside this keyboard here so you can see
the keyboard has similar slots to the
Raspberry Pi 4. it's basically a
Raspberry Pi 4 inside a keyboard case
it's important to remember that the
Raspberry Pi is just a computer it's a
small Linux computer and as such it
works very similarly to most other
computers particularly computers using
the Linux operating system
so what about the R4 pie project what is
it what is it what's it do so the R4 Pi
Project provides pre-built
um binaries of the r language first of
all but also provides a cram-like
repository
um where we make available
pre-compiled versions of uh cram
packages now we don't do all of cran
um maybe one day right now we're just
doing a subset of crown so we're
building somewhere in a region of 250
maybe 300 packages something like that
at the moment but we're adding more all
the time
um the way that this benefits users is
that
um if you're unaware if you're a Linux
user and you use cran cran give you the
source code rather than a pre-compiled
binary like they do for Windows and Mac
and this is great
um because R knows how to build them and
things like that but it can be very time
consuming there are often dependencies
which aren't necessarily met in your
build environment and so the R4 Pi
Project builds those packages for you
and then makes them available
um in this regard it's very similar to
our Studios package manager but
obviously on a much smaller on a much
smaller scale
with those packages available it becomes
much easier for you our users on the
Raspberry Pi to install those packages
the installation is much quicker and
there's no build that needs to occur
um and from there people can get started
much more quickly with r itself without
having to worry about all of this build
stuff
okay so let's take a look at a couple of
examples
um in this first one I'm gonna log in to
the Raspberry Pi
via SSH from an iPad so this is my
little kind of desktop iPad setup that
I've got going on I'm going to use a
program called blink to SSH into the
Raspberry Pi this basically gets me a
kind of Linux terminal but on the iPad a
butterfly flew into my office and I've
typed the password wrong as a result
uh okay so we're logged in and we're
going to run our looks exactly like R
does everywhere else
what we can do though is if we look at
options repo so if we look at the
repository that's set our kind of
default crayon is actually packages.r
for pi.org which is the cram like
repository that we maintain as part of
the R4 Pi Project so that Repository
contains the pre-built binary packages
that we've talked about and
um
when you install them it does what R
usually does which is ask you if you
want to create a personal Library if you
haven't already done so
then it will download those packages
from r4pi.org
download will take a moment so we might
just speed through that a little bit
then once the packages are downloaded
um you'll see that it says installing
binary package curl and installing
binary package RC
rcpp and so on and this is different to
what would happen if you installed those
packages from Crown if you installed
them from Crown it would say installing
Source package curl and so on and it
would try and compile those packages on
the Raspberry Pi which can be a very
time consuming
process and obviously there are
occasionally build dependencies and
things like that which we've all we've
taken care of for you with the alpha Pi
Project this makes installation a lot
faster and then once the packages are
installed you can load them as you would
normally in this example you see the
Raspberry Pi desktop so this would be
particularly useful you know if you're
using one of the larger Raspberry Pi's
Raspberry Pi or Raspberry Pi 400 and
we're actually going to do some work
inside an IDE so in this case we're
using visual studio code which is
available in the default Raspberry Pi
repositories and once that's fully
loaded you'll see that we have the r
extension installed and that the
R extension makes it possible for us to
do things like run individual chunks in
this R markdown document for instance
so in this case it's just running that
chunk now and you'll see that the
results come up in a window on the side
in a pane on the side I guess
um and you can knit the whole document
from here as well so just hit the knit
button and it's knitting the example
and then once that's knitted we can go
and take a look at it and it looks
exactly as you would expect it to it's a
very kind of basic our markdown document
obviously but hopefully proves the uh
proves the point
then we can also flip over to this
slightly more complex example and this
is a really really nice
ggplot2 plot example that I've borrowed
from the Palmer Penguins package website
and if we just step through that with
control and return as you would normally
step through and then when we go through
the last step it will print the plot in
the window on the side
we're quite zoomed in here so the uh for
kind of display purposes but as you can
see when we when we actually look at the
plot in more detail it looks exactly as
you would expect it to look
okay in this last example we're going to
take a look at a shiny application
so this is the shiny application
um fairly fairly standard stuff
and we're going to run that directly
from the terminal on the Raspberry Pi so
to do that we use uh the Chinese
built-in function which is just run app
so shiny double colon run app
and then when we hit return on there
the application will start now this is
only listening locally at the moment on
a random Port but if we go into the
Raspberry Pi's web browser we can take a
look at what that application looks like
so we put in localhost port number
and there it is so it's a blaster Fusion
model visualization the application is
not hugely important the point here as
much as anything is that the R4 Pi
Project enables you to do the things
that you can do everywhere else
simply and easily on the Raspberry Pi as
well
so
um it's a standard kind of application
there are some inputs which you can
manipulate which change the outputs a
little bit
um and that works you know in exactly as
you would expect
but what if
you want to run that persistently you
want to run that say on your on your
home network
well the Raspberry Pi can help with that
as well because of the Raspberry Pi's
low power draw requirements they make
ideal servers to run kind of 24 7.
so the way that we would do that for a
shiny application
is we would switch back to the terminal
we would drop out of the
um the running shiny application here so
we'll stop that
and then we'll run it again but this
time with a couple of extra parameters
so we're going to set the host to
0.0.0.0 that's basically just a way of
telling it to listen on the network
rather than just locally and then we'll
set a port so that it's easier for me to
find later on
once that's up and running
we can test it we can test and make sure
that that's available on the network so
to do that I'm going to flip over to my
iPad
and then once on the iPad I'm going to
type in the IP address or the hostname
if I have one of the machine on the
local network I'm using the IP address
here
and then I'm going to put in the port
that we specified earlier on
and we'll see if that loads and there we
go it's the exact same bastard Fusion
model visualization uh running in the
exact same way as before
um the the rendering is probably a
little different because we're using the
uh iPad web browser rather than the one
that's built into the Raspberry Pi
but other than that it works in exactly
the same way the same inputs connected
to the same outputs that change the
plots in exactly the same way
one of the things that I'm most excited
about about running are on a Raspberry
Pi is because it's a very small computer
you can run them in places where you
wouldn't normally run a you know one
thousand two thousand dollar computer
um they can be powered by batteries in a
lot of cases especially the smaller ones
you can run those from a USB battery
bank
but you can
imagine
ordinarily with data science people give
us data so the data is collected
somewhere it's bundled together often
not very well and then handed over to
the data scientists for kind of analysis
um but what we can do it with when we
have a small computer out there as we
fire is we can put that computer where
the data is collected so that could be
the data collection device as well as
the place where the analysis occurs this
kind of concept in Computing is often
referred to as Edge Computing because
you can take the centralized resources
that are often used for this sort of
work and you can move them to the edge
of the network
this means that you can run uh projects
in a lot more interesting places than
you might otherwise be able to
because of the low power requirements of
the Raspberry Pi you can run them in a
car while you're out parasending
I can imagine people running them while
they're you know on a building site or
in a digger
maybe even a farmer looking after cows
in a field
in a forest
on a boat the possibilities really are
uh endless with such a small low power
device
there are many different ways that you
could run the types of projects that
we've talked about
here today you don't need a Raspberry Pi
computer to do any of this stuff
um but for me the kind of low-cost the
um you know the kind of ease of entry
into the ecosystem is a really big boom
for for a certain class of users whether
they're people who are just you know
coming to R for the first time just want
to learn people want to learn Linux so
that they can use r on Linux because
obviously that's more or less a de facto
operating system for scientific and
Technical Computing at this point
um or for any other reason
um just having something that's very low
cost and very accessible for folks is a
really nice way to to help people get
into the the r ecosystem
thanks for watching the talk to this
point
um please check out the r4pi.org website
check out Raspberry Pi family of
computers if that's something that you
think you might be interested in
um my personal
website Twitter details are there as
well if you want them
um thanks again and I hope you have a
excellent rest of the conference
bye
[Music]